you ever watched the dude his name's Max
fosh I believe no no British guy no one
of his like recent videos over the last
couple months was it was called I
legally became Draco Malfoy's best
friend Tom Felton is the actor that
played Draco Malfoy right he's also a
musician you [__] with Tom Felton
yeah I do
Tom felt on these nuts so I guess like
Tom Felton is a pretty I don't know like
looked up to a guy he's a musician he
played Draco Malfoy he's a good actor so
this dude basically has this lawyer like
draft up a contract that says like I'm
your best friend if you sign this okay
right and like these are the
stipulations like once signed these are
the things you have to do it's like once
a year you have to wish me a happy
birthday and all these things and then
he he found out where Tom was gonna be
yeah like this like charity golf
tournament and he like got himself
submitted and he printed the contract on
a T-shirt and then like bumped into him
and asked him to sign his shirt like
wore the shirt underneath his golf oh I
think I've seen this just bumped into
him and be like hey could you sign my
shirt yeah and Tom was like sure yeah I
signed the shirt and they took it home
and was like now that's all all that's
required is for me to sign the other
side and we're officially best friend
like uh dude
oh my God another one he just recently
did was
like you know the phrase the elephant in
the room yeah he like wanted to figure
out what it felt like to actually have
an elephant in the room so he went to
like flew to Thailand just spent 24
hours in a room with an elephant right
that was pretty funny I just love ideas
like that yeah we just go all the way
yeah yeah I love [__] like that too
because you're it's just it sort of
feels like you're going all in every
time
and it's that's fun I'll tell you about
this one that I'm doing right now
since this is gonna be out after yeah
um
I like I'm gonna like basically prove
once and for all
whether DJing is easy or not oh they I
was gonna say that you could knock out
Jake Paul
yes you're gonna fight my next one
privately yes
yes just flatten them yep it's possible
I didn't film it but it definitely
happened yeah I definitely knocked his
ass out no basically I want to like
it's gonna be like Shaq
you know uh Paris Hilton all these
people like just decide to have DJ
careers and all of a sudden they have
them right so like what does that take
like is it do you have to practice like
what does it actually take to like play
a DJ set in front of people and get
booked and so I booked a show
in a month sick I'm playing Winston
House headlines set
s
so I went and it's in Venice okay it's
like a popular music venue in Venice I
mean it's like probably like it's like a
bar but it's probably like the Dance
Floor you fit like a few hundred people
there yeah like it's gonna be like
packed yeah
so I went I met up with Christian and
like had him make me like a tech house
song because I'm like well part of this
is like you need your own music yeah and
then I'm gonna meet up with Dylan
Francis next week he's going to teach me
how to DJ
and then
and then I'm just gonna go practice and
then play a show
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm pretty excited
I mean that's that's tight yeah I think
you'll I think you'll do great
I mean who knows you know that's the
point is it easy we'll find out
crowds is like dude what if he's our
walk in the room what do you mean people
like this is bad here let's go to I mean
that that's what I'm that happened to me
in college yeah I told you about that
yeah yeah so that can that could very
well happen again I'll probably make
that part of the video it's like this is
you know I'm not like entirely new to
this but like
the technology has changed the whole
landscape has changed you know since I
evacuated the dance floor in college
ever since I dropped a nuclear bomb on
the tennis floor
might as well just yeah sprayed like
fart spray in the middle of the Dance
Floor
oh you should load the Miss cannons with
fart yeah
yeah that's actually a super funny
that's how you know your set is really
good as if people stick around bro dang
at a big ass Festival yeah it's so good
though
in a venue like that it's mean too
because it's got a you know it's got a
ceiling yeah yeah so the smell comes
back
it's not a at a festival I feel you
could load a cannon with a fart smell
and it would just go up in the air and
maybe some people get a whiff you know
that'd be so funny yes things were just
putrid
I bought people in the front row
yeah Excision
dude did you ever
I saved this
should see that Tick Tock of that dude
eating the century old egg
I was about to show you one too here let
me play this one first hit it
so this is she she sprayed fart spray in
the room and I guess her mom has like a
really tall oh hell yeah
oh my God what's that smell did you fart
Ed
oh come on
that's disgusting oh come on
come on come in another room
that's not even human
[Laughter]
it's so good there's nothing funnier
there's nothing funnier than that
did you see the one where the dude's
throwing marshmallows down from the
balcony these two girls are standing on
the balcony below and he's like throwing
marshmallows with the egg yeah there was
a raw egg down it lands right in her
mouth
why did you do that
that one that one kills that one kills
dude I feel sick
[Music]
very aromatic thank you
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh my God
man I feel like I can taste that bro
cancel the rest of this episode oh my
God I can't believe that made you sick
did you not feel sick watching that I'm
not eating I feel like I can take I
could taste it I can smell it at one
point he's like he's like tastes like
sulfur that's what that's what I'm
smelling right now he goes in for round
two eating it from the wrong side of the
egg I was supposed to start on the side
that's gelatinous and slimy why does it
look like that almost looks like gray
water out of a septic tank
arms up
[Music]
[Applause]
you know I guess I have no choice
[__] Central he was trying really hard
yeah where do you even get those you
just order them online
yeah they look pretty crazy
you're supposed to eat them with things
that's insane looking right
man that that
I don't get gross out easily I feel like
in terms of food yeah man that that's
horrible I feel like the name is what
makes it worse than it is no but it's
just entirely black I get I mean you
think about what eggs look like in their
natural state it's like yeah what would
it take to get it there that's what I
mean if they tricked you though you know
like if they told you this no it's
overgrown boba
yeah okay you might go oh all right yeah
sure give me that yeah
that guy who snorts all the Boba or like
inhales the boat it's just a vat of
[__] Century old eggs in Thai iced
tea
sucking them down bro